[Music]
american world war ii movies definitely
have their own genre they typically deal
with the american sense of duty
sacrifice and focus on a hero
participating in a battle against good
and evil vietnam war movies have their
own genre too
centering on conspiracy distrust and
moral ambiguity but is there a genre for
the iraq war what do iraq war films have
in common
it's certainly possible that not enough
time has passed for a strong narrative
about the american occupation of iraq
but it's been 17 years since we invaded
in 2003 and almost 30 years since the
first gulf war in that same time period
after the start of the vietnam war we
had classics like apocalypse now and the
deer hunter these films had already
defined the vietnam war genre the
anti-war movement swept the us
and defined the themes in films like
platoon where the american soldiers are
the antagonists the chaos and senseless
violence in the film shows us how the
country felt about the war at that time
the genre elements of world war ii and
vietnam war movies reflect american
feelings about those conflicts
but what are the genre elements of iraq
war films let's see if we can find any
common threads
what's the best way to to go about
disarming one of these things
the way you don't die one of the most
prominent iraq war films is catherine
bigelow's 2008 best picture winner the
hurt locker it's about a reckless but
prolific explosive ordnance disposal
technician and his team as they count
down their days until deployment is over
sergeant james is the best of the best
he's technologically gifted
unfazed by high stress situations and is
in and out with little to no mess
in short he's a specialist iraq war
films typically focus on special forces
and that's because
unlike in world war ii and vietnam there
was no draft the draft made war
something everyone had to possibly
participate in whether they wanted to or
not
that's why world war ii and vietnam
films tend to focus on the grunts the
enlisted infantrymen who are just cogs
and a much larger machine
they are the everyman tom hanks is a
schoolteacher in saving private ryan and
the main characters in the deer hunter
are steel mill workers
these films tell the stories of average
joes who get caught up in the chaos and
can't wait to go home
you know if going to ramel and finding
him so he can go home if that earns me
the right to get back to my wife well
then
then that's my mission in direct
contrast iraq war films are about people
who want to be there and sometimes they
actually thrive in the chaos
without a draft the iraq war was more
removed from everyday american life
adding the fact that a large part of the
military in the middle east was made up
of mercenary contractors and the
american army turned into a job for just
a select few who chose to be there iraq
war movies center on a warrior class of
specialized units such as in the film's
american sniper zero dark 30 and the
hurt locker
got tools got two all right let's rock
and roll man
sergeant james in the hurlocker
perfectly embodies the warrior-class
mentality of american soldiers in the
iraq war
he's a specialized elite soldier
equipped to deal with the exact nature
of the war
in his first scene in combat he expertly
diffuses a massive roadside bomb
right off the bat we see he has the
technical expertise that an enlisted
soldier would not have
and his technical expertise applies to
more than just diffusing the bomb itself
before he defuses the bomb he also
defuses a tense situation with an iraqi
civilian
the film sets up sergeant james as a
warrior soldier that can do it all
he not only defuses bombs he also
defuses conflict
so a key genre element of many iraq war
films is the painting of american
soldiers as vocational well-trained
warriors that can deal with both combat
and civilian occupation
american sniper focuses on a highly
specialized sniper who can spot a bad
guy amongst the civilians
and other films like lone survivor and
zero dark 30 exclusively show elite
special forces who avoid civilian
casualties
active valor took this fixation on
specialized forces to the extreme and
recruited real-life seals to portray
themselves
clearly playing into the admiration of
elite talent
the emphasis on small elite groups and
their interactions with civilians makes
these films feel intimate and personal
most of these films dive into the
psychology of being a soldier
trauma is a common topic in many iraq
war films
many of the films show the soldiers at
home and the trauma that they bring with
them
these films are very sympathetic to the
ordeals that a soldier goes through
which contrasts the infamously poor
treatment of vietnam soldiers by the
american public when they returned home
there are quite a few iraq war films
that focus heavily on the trauma of
combat like yellow birds thank you for
your service and american sniper which
devotes its last act to addressing chris
kyle's post-traumatic stress disorder
spending more time on the psychological
effects of war shows america's new
understanding of mental illness and
contrasts with earlier war films that
either overlooked trauma resolved it
easily or went to the extreme and showed
soldiers as just psychotic
but highlighting the trauma of american
soldiers and limiting the scope of the
film to a specialized few has a
secondary effect it ends up avoiding
broader questions about whether the iraq
war was justified in the first place
like many iraq war films the hurt locker
treats america's presence in the war
as fact and does not question the war in
any meaningful way
and another film that also overlooks the
morality of the iraq war is the most
successful iraq war movie american
sniper
i just protected my guys they were
trying to kill our soldiers and
i'm willing to meet my creator and ask
for every shot that i took
chris kyle is the prime example of a
dutiful soldier in the film he's
motivated exclusively by a desire to
protect the lives of his teammates he's
willing to put himself in extremely
dangerous situations if it means he can
save lives i'm gonna go clear houses
with marines
and though these experiences cause him
trauma the film ultimately tells us it's
worth it because he saved american lives
your dad he's a hero on the surface this
stance appears apolitical because kyle
is just protecting soldiers in dangerous
situations but did those soldiers have
to be there in the first place
earlier in the film chris kyle's dad
lectures him on the importance of using
violence to protect
others and while he lectures the film
cuts to chris as a child
using violence to protect his brother
and then there are those who've
been blessed with the gift of aggression
and the overpowering need to protect the
flock
this scene clearly serves as an analogy
for chris's role as a sniper in the iraq
war he's just
using violence to protect people in
danger but if you look at this fight as
a metaphor for the iraq war the moral
justification breaks down
was beating up this other kid really the
only option to protect his brother
and did he really have to continue
punching the other kid even after his
brother already escaped
even though the film appears to not take
a stance one way or the other on the
validity of the war the narrow focus on
the individual totally simplifies the
moral greatness of the actual iraq
invasion nowhere along the way doesn't
consider that the best way to support
the troops is to keep them out of harm's
way in the first place and it never
questions whether troops are actually
improving the situation in iraq the film
tries to evoke the same feeling
americans had during world war
ii there was good and evil and we had to
fight on the side of good no matter the
cost
i just want to believe in what we're
doing here well there's evil here we've
seen it
in reality the iraq war has much more in
common with the moral grayness of
vietnam because both conflicts have
since been seriously questions
all across the political spectrum so
really american sniper tries to give a
world war
ii type moral absolutism to a vietnam
war type conflict
and other popular iraq war films also
try redressing the iraq war with a
morally righteous story
zerodark 30 is honest about some
controversial aspects of the war but it
still avoids questioning the war itself
the film justifies the shocking torture
scenes by having the torture result in
crucial information about bin laden's
whereabouts
in reality america discovered midlands
location from surveillance
not torture and torture has been
routinely questioned as an effective
interrogation tactic
just like american sniper this film
creates a scenario where the
justification for violence appears
obvious but only because the film framed
that scenario in a way that overlooks
the broader context of the war
contrast these films with films like
platoon and the deer hunter where the
horrors of war crimes are addressed
head-on and clearly portrayed as a
mistake
or even world war ii films like saving
private ryan where interesting questions
do get raised about the justification of
their mission
because world war ii and vietnam war
films make moral judgments about their
respective conflicts that honesty allows
them to address more interesting
questions about war
in general overall mainstream iraq war
films focus on specialized experts and
their individual experiences in combat
and that focus means that these films
rarely address moral issues about the
iraq war as a whole
not to mention they completely overlook
the iraqi perspective
maybe this is why the genre doesn't have
its apocalypse now if a war film wants
to be truly great it needs to confront
the messy reality of the war that it's
about
although most mainstream iraq war films
avoid the messy realities there are some
films that do address american
involvement in the middle east
in challenging ways what the [ __ ] are
you even doing here
sir i got lost on the way to college sir
jarhead is a 2005 film about infantry
men in the gulf war though it is about a
different war
its time of release setting and subject
matter make it feel comparable to an
iraq war film and unlike most iraq war
films
jarhead does have something insightful
to say about american involvement in the
middle east
in the film swafford's character
satirizes the american fantasy of a
morally justified war effort it feels
almost as if swafford watched american
sniper and got the impression that he
could be a hero too but from the
beginning the film rejects the idea that
he's a morally righteous character doing
the right thing
he was manipulated into joining the
military he's sickly obsessed with
killing
i wanted the pink mist and in the end he
was completely worthless to the war
effort
i never shot my rifle after a grueling
experience in boot camp and months of
waiting in the hot desert
all the soldiers want is to get into
battle but when it finally comes the
enemy retreats almost instantly american
air power easily overpowered the iraqi
army
damn you too [ __ ] slow they already
retreat all right we can shoot a
thousand yards
to go that far in vietnam that'll take a
week more one a year
here it's gonna take about 10 [ __ ]
seconds they then spend the rest of the
film walking through the carnage brought
by a war that moves too fast for them
and when swafford finally gets his
chance to fire his weapon
what the [ __ ] frequency are you on [ __ ]
we got air i'm calling it in like other
iraq war films it focuses on the
experience of the american
soldier but that experience is not one
of duty and honor it's one of
psychological torture the scars they
bring home aren't shown as sacrifices
for our freedom
instead the film leaves you asking what
was it all for in one particularly
poignant scene
swafford and his battalion cheer on the
flight of the valkyrie scene from
apocalypse now as if it's a football
game but that scene is itself a satire
of military heroism so when they cheer
it on they're obviously missing the
point
the film even gets cut off before the
explosions start so they never get their
climactic
ending this scene shows the soldier's
failure to even imagine a morally
justified conflict they completely
misread the messaging in apocalypse now
a film that actually reflects the chaos
and pointlessness of the vietnam war
this scene feels like a commentary on
war films in general
it's saying that people who watch war
films struggle to see the immorality of
war when focusing just on the spectacle
of american soldiers in combat
and films like american sniper and zero
dark 30 further remove films from
reality by creating moral dilemmas that
avoid asking the actual tough questions
but jarhead does capture the true moral
ambiguity of the wars in iraq
in reality the gulf war and iraq war
were far more complex
and jarhead addresses the pointlessness
of american involvement
in the middle east instead of relying on
a simple support our troops narrative
that doesn't really have anything
insightful to say about war
whether you supported the war or were
against it the reality is that many
americans felt like swafford watching a
war that didn't make sense
completely unable to either help or
stand against it
we are still in the desert
jarhead had mixed reviews when it came
out in 2005.
though skepticism of the war was high
americans may have been disappointed
with a meandering story without the
violent catharsis they thought they
would get when they bought their tickets
to a war film but looking back it might
have been ahead of its time to this day
we are still involved in military
operations in the middle east with no
end in sight
the violence that happens abroad is
abstract and removed from the american
people
films like the hurlocker and american
sniper represent an escapist desire to
create clear lines between good and evil
in the middle east but the reality is
far more complex there's still plenty of
time for more films like jarhead
to come out that bring a more nuanced
take on ideas of heroism and violence
and i think they will but while that
happens we're all still in the desert
if you liked the topic of this video we
also recorded a podcast episode
talking more in depth about war movies
click on the link in the description to
listen to it yourself
and give us feedback on what you think
and as always a big thanks to our
patreon supporters who watched this
video a week in advance and got early
access to the podcast
thanks for watching